- [Announcer] Three, two, one!
(canon explodes)
Blastoff!
("Entrance of the
Gladiators" by Julius Fucik)
Please welcome our first trapeze in the air,
the Fabulous Flying Bell!
(crowd clapping)
- There's a certain feeling of adrenaline
once you get up there in the air.
It's a feeling unlike any other.
(relaxing music)
You feel power,
you feel like you're in control.
You feel special.
That's what makes trapeze beautiful.
That's what makes the circus beautiful.
My name is Kristin Finley
and I'm a trapeze artist.
15 years ago I was working
for a brewery in Los Angeles.
I had a great life making great money.
I had my Lexus and I had a house.
I was only 24 years old.
A friend of mine told me
that she was flying trapeze.
And I said what are you doing?
I want to come watch.
I ended up taking a
class and I was hooked.
It was addictive right away.
And I quit my life in L.A
and I joined the circus.
I went from good pay to zero pay.
Just had to give everything
up pretty much overnight
and here we are 15 years later.
I never looked back and I've
been on the road ever since.
(train whistle blowing)
To run away and join the circus,
it takes commitment.
You have to be ready for anything.
You have to kind of live on your toes
because you never know
what's going to happen.
Your own personal space,
your RV or whatever,
that's your home.
And that's what has to be stable inside.
Whenever you're flying trapeze,
you have to focus on what you're doing.
And the moment you doubt yourself
in the middle of a trick,
most likely you're gonna mess up.
You're not gonna make it.
The fact that I was able to do it
made it more appealing to me.
And I'm doing these
tricks and they're harder,
and they're harder, and this is awesome.
Whatever you want to do
in your wildest dreams,
do it.
Anything's possible.
There's not too many African American
female circus performers,
but I was still able to do it.
Your life is what you make of it
and I wouldn't change
my life for the world.
I really wouldn't.